韓國今天又大熔斷了
一度大跌8%
今年以來跌了6次的熔斷
但這次不一樣
好像跌破季限
真的是來真的嗎
台股這次也跌真的嗎
會受影響
感覺這次可能不太一樣
我跟獨家告訴大家
這次有沒有可能是來真的
所以台股今天開高走低
1500點
很扯吧 莉莉
而且韓國股市一度大跌8%
三星的錯
三星的財報
明明好的要命
为什么大家觉得三星的错呢
那现在来了
跌人这样子7月
还能52万吗
今天反复跌了2000点
3000点
怎么会这样子呢
今天独家说明这三大重点
我一切一切
我要预告告诉大家
现在台湾股市
What's wrong with
我们的台股了
台湾股市发生什么事情
今天独家告诉大家
台股今天风云变色
又是超过千点的大震荡
开盘一度大涨400多点
但盘中眼看本来要突破47000
反而变成大跌千点
投资朋友们都很紧张
也好奇是否是因为韩国大跌溶断
导致牵连到台股
想知道究竟是什么原因造成台股大震荡
这是来真的吗
投资长又是怎么看的呢
接下来就交给我们经济日报选股冠军
单季188%的记录保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
國哲榮投資長
投資長好
Liddy 各位同朋友大家好
今天台灣股市看起來不太妙
韓國股市的啊
哎呀 跌成這樣子
咪咪媽媽媽咪咪
你自己看一下韓國股市
今天正式要跌破這季限了
收盤正式還是跌破
然後上台有收斂一點
你看你不要看這個行情不怎麼樣
你也不要覺得韓國股市
我一直說韓國股市會影響台灣股市
我是不是一直講過莉莉
是
你看韓國股市現在已經跌破了這邊
台灣股市在這邊
我記得沒錯的話
是4萬點的一個關卡
我記得沒錯是4萬點的關卡
4萬點
它現在已經回到這邊
我看一下這邊是什麼時候
6月 6月的低點
應該這邊是4萬點
我們看一下我們同時對照
這6月嘛 對
對
看這6月的低點
台灣股市6月的低點是什麼時候
我們看一下
6月的低點
應該是說這邊
6月的低點這邊
這邊有沒有 4萬2
我更正
韓國股市已經回到這邊
4萬2的地方了有沒有
這4萬2我看到沒有
有沒有
這邊啊
直接看一下就好
4萬2
好那我們來看一下
這6月的低點
6月有沒有
6月的低點有沒有
好
看一下喔
有感覺喔
要有feel喔各位
有沒有
這個已經回到這邊
6月份了
你們看到
6月份在韓國股市
有沒有看到
是
所以韓國股市
大概就回到差不多4萬2
可是現在台灣股市呢
不好意思
歷史還在4萬5
這就是為什麼台灣股市
後來擊殺的原因之一
因為台灣股市不可能
一個人一直獨秀
有時候反而變成強奴之末
那為什麼韓國股市跌人這樣子
兩大原因
我昨天就說台幣這貶值很重要
你看今天頭版新聞
我看到
你有沒有發現到為什麼這麼多新聞
所以你去講一件事
一個分析師
每天跟你講強勢股
講他被動元件很強
我記憶體很強
結果最重要的總體基金
資金的資金潮移開的時候
講不到兩個字
講不到台幣貶值
你覺得這樣對嗎
為什麼我每次給你講的一個重要新聞
隔天變成頭版新聞
莉莉沒錯吧
沒錯
你看台幣貶破32元
這也是今天台灣股市大跌的原因啊
你自己看
你不知道以為說出現哪支標股
這不是標股
台幣往上漲是貶好不好
你本來30塊換一美金的
現在變32塊你開心嗎
不開心
是不是
所以台幣貶人這樣子已經穿一個
你看
思雅這個多一點的
請思雅這個多一點截圖
應該是4月以來的低點
你懂不懂
那等於台灣股市4月以來的低點什麼時候
那時候台灣股市4月以來的低點
這邊這邊
從3萬
遮住了
等一下喔
氣死了
你看這個
不好意思
這軟體不好用
唉
我跟你講喔
這只是很戀舊
不要每天念念念
我只是很念舊啊
不過再來我要拋棄永豐軟體了
實在是你知道嗎
所以我覺得台灣的券商
真的競爭不太激烈你知道嗎
你知道嗎
我覺得只要有一個有遠見的人
好好研發一套軟體
像元大現在軟體就不錯
也覺得元大軟體不太好用
他現在下單手機軟體不錯
電腦下單軟體
再一個人好好研發
我覺得就很容易取代
好啦這扯遠的啦
永豐這個有沒有
31529點有沒有到
有
我們放大一點念力可以嗎
從3月底
這是3月底喔
4月初也是差不多3萬2喔
有沒有看到
沒錯吧
來 我們這邊
4月底這邊也是3萬2
有沒有看到
是
所以應該是4月初
只是那時候動手說是那時候
4月初也是3萬2
有沒有看到
我們來看一下
再放大
大概4月初
也是差不多3萬1 3萬2
從3萬2以來
台灣股市一直漲靠是內資
因為外資全部落跑了
新台幣也捲走了
你說新台幣賣走了
美元捲走了
金融幣賣光光了
所以這個台幣貶值要注意一下
這是賣壓
但是去年前年有一陣子貶到3233
32元的時候
台灣股市還是不動胡三
可是現在來了
我一直說了
你那支要有錢
可是現在看什麼
不好意思
現在券商也不見你錢了
4%的一個利息
之前在2.6%
質壓利率2.6%跟4%差很多
是
以前你就說
OK啦
我半根整停板給你就好了
現在不一樣
斤斤計較
現在賺個2 3%都很難賺
是不是
是不是沒錯吧
對
你看現在00981A有看到沒有
主動同意有沒有看到
這一根長黑K
00981A基本上它已經從什麼時候
它從5月以來到現在基本上
不要說5月啦
對 從5月這邊是5月有沒有看到
5月以來
5月以來它就在一個區間整理團整裡面有沒有看到
有
這5月有沒有看到
根本不動如山啊
是不是 那大家如果是我直壓
直壓股票去買00981A 我現在是賠錢啊
我每天要繳利息啊 所以有些人資金會縮手
這個會變成一個惡性循環
可是我告訴你 從頭到尾你就不應該去借錢
像韓國股市會跌的原因是很多人去買正惡啊
夭鬚 我覺得韓國股市大跌
是啊 那個給我三星跟海利斯的走勢啊
一堆股票大跌特跌 你能不懂
現在為什麼很多股票會跌成這樣子
跟三星海利斯一樣啊 因為展的莫名其妙啊 各位
你去看一件事情
我有沒有說為什麼國具
我說國具我是說國具跌會跌很快
你看國具直接殺跌停板
為什麼跌很快
很多人跟我一樣是300元 400元 500元買啊
我今天管理是900元 1000元
我隨便賣今天跌停板啊
所以我說這個國具你不要碰你們不理我
1200到900塊跌很快欸
他之前最高1220元欸
現在變900塊欸
Lily一下子省300塊你不覺得很誇張嗎
是的
是啊
这多少我看一下
905除以1220
等一下啊
一下子显得26%
比那时候环球金杀还杀得很凶
可是环球金跌25%我是敢买
被动元件你跌25%你敢买
你不要跟我讲什么缺货什么东西啊
夜间人都知道这个又不像机体一样
被动元件的技术含量拿那么大
你不要开玩笑你知道吗
又不像机体缺成那样子
你拿我展的
沒有像記憶體缺的這樣子
結果展的比記憶體還強
不是這種展法的
現在大家突然清醒你知道嗎
我選的股票跟別人選的股票不一樣
你看我解盤就跟人家不一樣
那我們要去批評人家
者者現在就是一個不好意思
者者就是我後也已經人數夠多了
者者也已經財富自由了
重點不是財富自由
我也讓很多人財富自由
就算沒財富自由也沒關係
我現在的心態就是
幫大家賺錢
我最後
我幫大家賺錢就最後
所以我沒有一定要收很多會員
所以這一波為什麼大家其實我們這邊會員
不會去受傷很嚴重
我問你一件事啦
今天啦
6488環球星跌停板啦
那要怎麼樣
我還是賺100多%啊
你聽懂嗎
是
我還是賺100多
昨天多少
昨天是150是不是
我今天還賺130 140啊
昨天是150嘛對不對
對
不對也沒關係
你印象中是150%嘛對不對
有到150
150%
環球星今天再跌我也沒差
跌我也沒差
而且我有沒有說環球金要跌
有沒有說
有
我說環球金跌
我才能買中美金啊
我說再不跌的話要被處置了啊
禮拜四就要被處置了
禮拜三禮拜四就被處置了
我說不能再漲啊對不對
是
所以環球金慢慢來嘛
這段時間休養過後
我跟妳講環球金到時候很快要2000塊
妳到時候會發現
環球金很快要2000塊
可是國際呢
很難2000塊啊
這件事喔
同樣那時候是1000塊喔
他們都是從500塊開始漲喔
妳會發現到到最後
500塊到2000塊也是環球金 不是國均
就有這句話
記得有這句話
我的股票比別人勉強
業界都知道這些東西
你聽懂嗎
好不好
都知道事情
只是他們
老師有些老師展聽板
做萬計你風險了
當然他們不在乎啊
他們不會去管台幣啊
台幣本來就一個大利控
32元扁破這個還不危險喔
四五月來的
從台幣
那時候台灣股市32000也是32
台幣也是32元別那麼慘
現在台灣股市46000也是32
代表外資辣跑只是內資撐
那些內資怎麼撐
錢又被收一半了
然後現在韓國股市賞物也被收走了
你知道嗎
不只耶 是喔
所以
是喔給我那個台幣
台幣算什麼時候新
快要了
已經是快要了有沒有
是疫情來了有沒有看到
可是如果是接下來收盤這樣
如果央行沒有去喝止它的話
有可能是收盤價的新低喔
那個32.196嘛
今天32.16有沒有
有可能是今年
事曉是不是今年以來的第二低
台幣貶的第二低
台幣的價格最低
32點多
幸好我最近我有換一些美金
好不好
為什麼我換美金
因為我愛美元中美金
沒有啦
美金喔
暗示自然股票
暗示妳愛美金有沒有
是不是
莉莉有沒有覺得
不錯
我愛美元 台幣扁的
這個沒有啦 伯君一笑啦
我跟你講 你們要下來是要把它當禮物
台灣股市就算萬一今天這個月沒有5.2萬
你也把它當禮物
沒有關係
因為AI還是在進漲
好不好
記憶體我覺得適度的下去
對台灣股市沒有什麼不好
所以我來講一件事
用紀錄線型來講
南亞科
這邊的底部不能破
這邊底部破就危險了
我先暗示你了
好不好 我暗示你
我賺很多了
這邊的底部
385 386
這邊不能跌
你知道嗎 38啦
記得好不好
森拔森拔跳舞吧
沒有 人笑話
好不好 OK嗎
那台幣是今年收盤最低
台幣他剛剛講今年收盤最低
還沒收盤吧
台幣還沒收吧
是啊 台幣好像還沒收
可是如果等一下收盤
是這個價格的話
就是今年收盤最低點
台幣扁到今天收盤最低點OK 收盤價來說的話 好不好你看今天三星 海利市好像是從 2000 年到現在好像只有韓國股市
實施這個壟斷制度
只有12次而已
人家想看有金融海嘯
台灣股市金融海嘯天天跌停板
它有12次
反正就實施以來12次的壟斷
有6次在今年
6次
今年就6次了
就6次 像到你對不對
這個波動太大了啦
是
難怪海力士他們最近股價跌
因為他們員工都不上班
都在做股票
都太刺激了 開玩笑
來啦 我跟你講平常星
跌就買 跌就補
跌就補
跌就補補你的部位 知道嗎
日語就不用擔心
三星在這邊
為什麼三星這樣子
你看 我跟你講這種東西
不要緊張 為什麼不要緊張
這叫做利多找理由
我先講為什麼利多找理由
當然我跟你講
如果韓國再跌下去
台灣股市會殺
因為你看韓國股市殺到季線
我們看台灣股市的季線
他人家搶也不能
你看我把它移一下
看季線就知道很恐怖喔
我們這是月線對不對
我改一下
60MA
夭壽喔
月線不知道
42.2
所以我剛才講的是很準
說42.2對不對
是
是不是
我看這邊不是42.2
已經回到人家這邊嘛
對不對
對
來這邊42.2嘛對不對
這邊42000有沒有
這邊就是42000
所以你看現在這邊有沒有
這邊42000有沒有
對過去就搞這條線
一樣嘛對不對
對
所以這邊是42000
人家已經跌到這邊42000了
台灣股市多3000點
要小心
就韓國股市不能一直跌
你說一直跌台灣股市沒辦法自身4000
你還記得這件事
然後長也AI 疊也AI
講話同時韓國怎麼樣
那個廣達營收我剛才沒看錯
投資朋友如果等一下有最新營收
你也可以提醒我
廣達公佈什麼最新營收
哇營收很厲害耶
是啊 做圖給我看
那個營收表
還沒做
我們來看一下
它營收月增23%
很強耶
是
營收上個月已經很高
這個月更高
以上個月多23%
所以歷史新高的營收
好不好 歷史新高的營收
來啦 先看一下你們有什麼問題
股票不用擔心
哲哲都選基油股
我高基級的股票
比如說 問你一件事
今天鴻海也有跌
你覺得它能跌多慘
這種越跌你反而越要買
你聽得懂的意思嗎
它是因為全資股的關係
可是你看鴻海跌喔
它怎麼跌到時候不會跌得比台達電長
台達電到時候會跌很兇喔
你知道嗎 如果台灣股市殺下去的話
是
國劇也是一樣 殺下去很恐怖喔
你懂嗎
國劇一下就跌25%
我們畫面也給我一下
我看有一些股票今天跌很慘
來來
然後金像店 2368
金像店 破底了喔
金像店破底了有沒有看到
是不是
3037星星 也要破底了喔 是不是
星星好像做個M頭喔
星星這個線型頭不好看
我們跟他講說星星他漲上1000塊
他強任他強
我獲得力大概100
我沒記錯165%左右
165 167
好不好
以我之前講的為主
至少賺100%我敢確定
他強任他強在AMP
這線型目標比較好
所以有些股票真的危險
你懂嗎
有些股票真的危險
好不好
這是跟大家講的
所以至少我們的股票很OK
你看
我連發課我出掉
現在有沒有人抱怨
今天又跌破4000元了
是不是
雖然拉到40 30
但其實年發科最好賺的我走了
你懂不懂
你就把人家最青春年華
這樣
不是
做男人不要當渣男
但是做股票你要當渣男
你懂我意思嗎
懂
什麼意思
你把人家最青春年華的
這一段拿走了
年頭那個魚頭魚尾送給人家
這件事做人你不要當渣男
但投資股票你要當渣男
你要把人家最青春年華
人家最成長期的這個果實
拿走
知道嗎
拿走就好了
連發科我就拿這一段就好了
後面我不理他嘛
是不是
我拿這一段是不是開心
是
這加全指數
你記不記得那時候連發科多少錢
一千
記不記得一千四百三十
有沒有記得
沒有
沒關係
要記起來
我常講
一千四百三十對不對
有沒有印象
有
一千四百三十到
4970元
這一段最好賺
我沒到4,900走掉
因為我要確定它漲不上去再走
1,400到4,000元這一段
最好賺嘛對不對
對
這一段我就當這個渣囊
賺到就好了
其他我不管啦
國具也是一樣啊
國具六七百元走掉
那要怎麼樣
我就賺這一段啊
我賺這一段可不可以
六七百元
賺這一段可不可以
這一段也賺了快100%啊
是不是
是
快100啊
約100%啊
後面我不管他嘛
反正後面有可能做個頭嘛
我們就是採取最精華的一段好不好
我給你們看一下
所以同學你今天看的人應該比較多
我們看一下
今天點綠我猜
今天直播人數我猜
現在已經5500到6000直播人數
我看一下
我滿準的
那個
依依你可以做證
我剛才有打開這個頁面嗎
沒有
因為他有監控我的
你不能打開
打開你都知道啊
對不對
我現在切什麼畫面你都知道啊
是不是 我如果切這個畫面
你會知道
對不對
所以我是很準
所以我抓直播
你不覺得我連抓直播人數都很準
我剛才說5千5到6千
是
所以相信我判斷
這邊拉回
台灣股市有機會破五彎
真的 我不能說百分之百
但我的思覺很強
好不好
今天帶Tiffany面這個
Tiffany面很漂亮
可以秀一下給粉絲嗎
謝謝你 謝謝你
今天疊位是因為美國輸嗎
全國足球書這支
哪有什麼差啊
是不是
台積然可以買
台積然隨時可以買
好不好
台積然隨時
0050隨時可以買
好不好
股市柵欄
折折專業
蝶就有6000人看
國際要不要說句話
國際已經說句話了
好不好
智原型人大概跟大家講
直播6000人怎麼概念
還好
小蝶概念
中蝶就是8000人
大蝶
剩下破底應該就1萬人
直播
你們都這樣子
都哲哲牧師啊
大跌才想到我
你們也是渣男渣女啊
你們比我還渣
都跌的時候還想到我
展的時候
逍遙的時候
賺大錢的時候
一堆人忘記我
哲哲穿藍色的時候是因為跌嗎
那個藍色嘛
不錄啦 我不想錄了
沒有啦 沒有什麼原因啦
好不好
就是穿個GUCCI的衣服
只要穿一下而已好不好
台勝科也打八折
可以追嗎
如果說台勝科這場股票的話
來 打Buzzle就OK啊
雖然他之前EP是負的
我覺得我跟你講
環球金這種展代表
這個行業是展真的
你記得這件事好不好
春江水暖 鴨先吃
領頭鴨先吃
領頭鴨先知道 OK嗎
OK
直播人數6000人
6000人
都會一定會再提高了啦
正常 OK
我剛才說5500到6000嘛
等一下我再高
等一下再過10分鐘會再更高
以前3000人大跌
那個Name for Ever
你很不...
你今天雖然是第一個追我的
但是你很不了解我
我們3000人算少了 好不好
OK 則今天太冷靜了
沒什麼 這股市是這樣子
我跟你講 我不冷靜
我跟你講 我路很high的人
我還著金 我賺50%我就走了
我要賺100%了
如果不要回答沒關係
我問你件事
你會借錢嗎
基本上是我粉絲你不會借錢
就要你借錢你不會借太多
我說沒錯吧
你覺得我粉絲會亂借錢嗎
不會 那今天有什麼關係
那你還有沒有錢
我現在問你是你還有沒有錢
你沒錢你也不用煩惱啦
你還要進去的嘛
你還有錢你應該今天開心啊
就這個想法
我又不是叫你買國具
又不是叫你買年發科
又不是叫你買星星
這些股票我都丟掉了
我好激動
我的股票我都賺對了
星星有沒有賺一倍
年發科有沒有賺一倍
國具有沒有賺一倍
我沒有說啊
這股票都是耳熟人詢
大家知道股票
我全部都走了
是不是
是
挖心可以注意一下
那股票做頭啊
這東西見面
咻咻咻咻咻
1000多張就可以殺跌停
這蠻厲害的
好不好
所以我的股票疊一倍我就走掉了
所以平常星
6196帆軒
你看今天本來要串心
剛剛殺下去的
還有我跟你講3374精彩
你想買的我想再買
你想買的我覺得可以買
3374精彩我覺得不錯
你知道嗎
我跟你講
這就是為什麼
為什麼你說很多人
覺得我今天平靜
大風大浪我都看過了
股市不就這樣
很多人股市長個1000點
就覺得自己是股神
你知道嗎
長個1萬點
覺得我就是巴菲特
全世界最厲害的
連巴菲特不如我
其實從頭到尾
你跟我智商都沒有變
我為什麼會在股市中活那麼久
你還記得金字招牌
單分一是當快20年了
一路以來
我就是粉絲人數最多的
除了前期的前三年
为什么
因为我看到很多人没看到未来
你还记得我发明很多金句
不只发明国趣
贝东元庆我最了解
以前贝东元庆什么产案的
我赚到钱也有参与到
很多人只记得我后面让人家赔钱
不记得我前面让人家赚大钱
所以这些股市的高潮低潮
这我都遇过你知道吗
真的我都得也是
这些股市的高潮
小孩来切个图
你看
這小人就混
你看今天沒置中
攝影機有動過
對不對 沒錯吧
一一對不對
一看就要攝影機有動過
好 不然我置中一下
來 再轉
你看是不是沒置中
小人在混
沒關係 這是穿完畫面
所以我跟你講
為什麼我們團隊績效最好
因為就是有這麼機車的投資長
畫面一換我就知道
任何人都有惰性
則則也有惰性
你難者則會逼自己的惰性減到最少
所以我這樣平常心這沒什麼
這沒什麼
為什麼我們股票吉祥那麼好
沒什麼
我跟你講我這樣最恐怖
我跟你講
這最恐怖的是有以前的毅力
小韓請你不要調
掙錢換降 吃大忌
不要在我講話的時候調
你來不及了
對啊
寄生界沒有啦 開玩笑
我們這邊
好啦 反正這個
吃小錯 但我們不開心
好 來
承遠了
大風大難者都見過
為什麼我們計較好
因為整個真的很機車
好不好
你們剛剛看到嗎
畫面沒錯吧
你們再看一下
來這邊
來再切一下
沒有至中啊
是不是
OK
我切過來給我
所以機車投資長
能拍到桌子嗎
今天也沒有拍到
也不需要拍桌子
因為計較沒有到非常好
會員有打折嗎
有啊
會員的股票有打折啊
你們現在要買不是可以打折嗎
是啊
世界有機會上場
世界我就OK
跌20%
我就跌20%
世界金真的不應該跌20%
環球金這種展法
世界金不應該跌20%
買買買買買買好不好899群年899年今天跌太兇了但我跟妳講一件事喔群年我覺得先觀察一下因為記憶體整個趨勢現在不太對
妳懂嗎
可是如果你同時有群年跟南亞科
我會說如果南亞科
跌的話妳要走
因為南亞科長太多了
群年沒長很多
妳聽懂我意思嗎
懂
而且群年
事業給我那新聞
群年他們的執行長還在買
執行長只要願意砸錢買
我就相信他
就在美觀的時候
劉昂偉董事
就是台積電前董事長去買美觀
現在當他的董事長
那很多人笑啊
最後還不是漲很多
你懂嗎
那麼都有內幕消息
不要說內線交易
內幕消息
對不對
OK
這個好笑 真的打折價
對啊
會員的股票現在有些打折價
好 今天買都打折
南電呢
我跟你講
ABU宅板都扯了啦
都過高了
你都選過高的本益比
南電我覺得過高了
好不好
1000塊就有點扯了
你看他以前漲到多少錢
他們以前最多漲到月線
以前最多漲到600元就覺得很貴了
現在1000元你覺得便宜
EPS有沒有增加多少
缺貨缺貨
都有一點炒作
然後告訴你
這些股票沒下去我不買
這麼簡單
南電我也賺一堆
井碩我也賺一堆
比如在萊坂三雄
我就喜歡買底部的股票
不然怎麼樣 咬我啊
高了我就買
要買可以啊
要真正的什麼獲利有增加
比如台積電嘛
是
要聽那些什麼
再講一次
你不要聽什麼賣隔離
跟你講說一萬塊
研發科是有技術
技術護成核是不是
他技術不錯
當然他不到護成核這個階段
就是人家要跨過去很難
隨便隨時被搶單
你跟我說後年什麼
TPU 機片大賺錢
那都胡扯
CPU很多都胡扯
這不是分支技術
我只都知道主力的炒作的手法
或外資出貨
或者是故意出貨
或不小心出貨的手法
只是我再講下去
我覺得得罪太多人
我不講了
好不好 我不講了
不好意思
有時候大炮個性
但我現在也不喜歡攻擊別人
但如果有人攻擊哲哲
我又不會特別攻擊分析師
如果有人攻擊分析師
你記得一件事
他就是業績不好
業績好哪有時間看人家節目
沒錯
會分析分析師的分析師
業績一定差
那業績差代表什麼意思
績效不會很好
你相信有人有那種績效很好
然後業績很差的分析師嗎
就是每個股票攢一倍
然後業績很差
怎麼會這樣子
不太可能對不對
反正就不太可能
這是什麼社會了
你如果一攢股票
每個股票要暫停
所以我跟你講
不要說什麼績效很好
業績很差
業績差
基本上績效就不好
你會批評別人
代表績效不好
我不要扯遠了
我是告訴你
記得任何人都是一樣
好不好
如果哪一天我會成為這種人
那代表我也不太好
基本上我不會啦
來來
折折 致源慘烈犧牲
不要亂講
智元底部的股票
不会不会不会
智元就没涨
你们这样是被宠坏了
这个大概打八折
被宠坏了
最高点到现在
我觉得被宠坏了
但你说今天有跌了
OK吗
今天外资卖了547亿
头发变长了
谢谢
年电可以追吗
我去年电追
你不买世界先进
好不好
智元你看有人说没什么跌
有人说什么
别担心
外資賣547億
我跟你講喔
台幣不能在扁上去
在扁上去會加速賣喔
你知道嗎
是
會加速賣喔
加速賣
你要記得我這件事
加速賣好不好
來來來
來 廣達電腦
你看四條馬上出現那個圖
有沒有什麼營收公布的
四條給我
或者粉絲們你給我
我們很多
我很多也都是會員
給我一些資訊
所以我們資訊特別強
來喔 現在群人有沒有看到
二度加碼35張有沒有看到
有沒有看到
有
而且你看喔
你看喔 他一開始
他一開始是買4900萬你知道嗎
有沒有看到
一開始買4900萬
這一次買多少
8666萬
而且用月金價2476元看的話對不對
是
沒錯吧
那你們看一下我們現在資源多少錢
不是資源多少
群聯對不起
我剛才講群聯
群聯一開始他們董事長
來
看清楚
買的張數一開始對不對
買比較少張
價格比較低
現在買很多
現在價格越貴它反而比較多
你知道嗎
之前買1960元
買那幾張
買25張
現在買35張買更多
然後買了快2500元
好不好
你看群聯現在多少
連大老闆股票現在都打8折多
你在怕什麼
那聽懂嘛
我跟你講你就是那種要死一起死的觀點
你就不能擔心了
你懂不懂意思
群你也敢加碼
我去問你啦
你現在去問啦
你問國際董事長幹嘛加碼
你問南亞科董事長幹嘛加碼
你別說了啦
紅海可能還敢加碼
你懂不懂意思嗎
是
這就是我選的股票選那種
低基起的
公司大股東
董事長執行長都還會想加碼
不會不敢加碼的價位
你聽懂嗎
你去問聯發科可不可以加碼
我一堆身邊一堆科技業
靠聯發科賺大錢的
你看這個時候誰敢4000塊
也給你用力加碼
都是從頭報到尾的
你聽得懂嗎
懂
所以我選的股票是人家敢加碼的
你懂不懂
所以為什麼我說再疊下去
南亞科我反而會出
群聯我不一定會出
我會選就是人家老闆
人家執行長董事長還敢加碼
內部高層還敢加碼的股票
懂不懂我儘量選這些
我不能說100%
我儘量選這些
你知道嗎
這個整流二極體
最近真的很夯
可是你看
這個量一萬張八千張
我跟你講
等他以前量更少
一個股本成交量二十幾億
現在是不夠我塞牙縫
我是說真的好不好
二極體不用買就不要買了好不好
缺貨成這樣子
當然人家要炒都可以
因為他股本很小
看人家要不要炒而已好不好
所以我選股票還不錯
然後第二個再給你看最新的
來囉
所以現在群聯人家董事長
他現在是董事長還是什麼
因為換來換去
他之前有緋聞
他不是董事長
他變執行長
之前有緋聞
他不講人家八卦
不重要
他現在變執行長
連董事長
創辦人
我想是群聯
來
那管拿電腦也是一樣
有沒有看到
管拿電腦怎麼樣
營收有沒有看到
3850億有沒有看到
有
是營收
這逐月的營收 各一月的營收有沒有
你看這個也是用GEM來做的
投資朋友你怎麼會覺得GEM來
我覺得GEM來很好用耶
我現在很多在醫生
我看任何B字前
我在醫生我都先查好所有資訊
跟醫生講什麼
該開什麼藥大概都知道了
而且我跟你講
你知道嗎
醫生也是隔寒如隔山
比如我看內分泌科或看心臟內科
其實不一樣的東西耶
是
所以你其實
假設你心在內科
你要問那邊密科的事情
你不一定
你不要說不一定
基本上你不會贏AI
我們講事實你不會贏AI
你不查資料你不會贏AI
你不查資料你不會贏那些會查AI的人
你知道嗎
是
就連醫生都不同科
我不是在侮辱醫生
我講真的
而是我在稱讚AI
一般人用AI不同科
假設我心在內科
我要問那邊密科的東西
我會用AI
我還比心臟內科的人懂內分泌科
我該吃什麼藥
我想是真的
只要你會用AI
我常常跟很多分析師講
我說接下來
會用AI的人
AI不會取代人
你記得這句話
我會送給你們最大的禮物
AI不會取代人
是人會取代人 是不是
是會用AI的人取代你
是用這件事 AI不會取代的人
是會用AI的人會取代
不會用AI 懶得用AI的人
那一定被淘汰
一定被淘汰
你記得這句話
所以蜜蜜老生在在
蜜蜜不會被淘汰啊
我們隨便做個資料 管道料
你看就做得很漂亮
你看喔 網路上也很多人用AI圖
為什麼我們有頭褲
做的AI圖就特別漂亮
因為蜜蜜機車
懂不懂 再看一下
你看這個小孩
你看畫面給我 自衝嗎
當我電報他
可能今天心情也不好
好 隨便這樣電
不會啦 我心情不好玩
不會讓電子這樣
懂不懂
為什麼我做圖的時候
所以會用AI的人
會比不要用AI
或懶得用AI的人
或不用AI的人
會把它取代掉
好不好 你看做的圖很漂亮
隨便 也沒幾分鐘而已
為什麼我們做AI圖特別漂亮
然後上半年營收1.85兆元
有沒有看到
有沒有 Q2的營收
首次突破一兆
代表的是說你看
它是累積越多
一劑比一劑還增加很多
Q2嘛
等於Q1大概0.85兆
Q2一兆嘛 對不對
對
大概大概 已經大於一兆
然後6月營收3851億
逐月增加的營收有沒有看到
數算數算圖多輕鬆 清楚
所以不要擔心
很多人說AI泡沫
那最多最容易泡沫是
哇 大家怎麼樣
AI還在成長
然後AI投資減少
應該這樣講
AI還在成長
不是AI投資減少
應該說AI還在成長
但AI股不成長
結果泡沫了
或AI還在成長
還在投資很多AI
你知道嗎
可是問題是股價估值過高
比如說我投資的AI
我投資了一兆美金
假設啦 一兆美金
可是我這些股票EPS的市值
可能只有500元
就從中漲到1000元
那就有可能泡沫了
OK嗎
OK
來 小韓被處置了
小韓被處置了
找到裁縫尾
對啊
不是找到裁縫尾
對只能擠車
來來
有問題可以先問AI找出問題的大方向
真的 阿克你要會問喔
Cloud分析的利比圈還好用
我看的我覺得還好耶
Cloud應該是寫程式的
我看還好耶
真的有嗎
我再去試一次
我試以後我發現我
不行喔
我就Cloud分析的利比圈還好
你寫的是程式方面吧
我不確定
願聞其想
請問華班電可以續報則
我又不是我真的折粉
你問我是幹嘛啦
這錫板
滑板店已經破底了
滑板店這個底比那個還醜
你看 怎麼看怎麼破底 你看
是不是這邊彈又對不對
反彈有沒有過前高 沒有
沒有 反彈也沒過前高
那今天的低點是比前面還低
是 底部
底底低 底部比底部還低
高點越來越低
底部也越來越低 有沒有看到
有 這很典型的
你要在三天內趕快站穩180元
就這邊價格
不然很危險
好不好 僅限位置區
好不好
那你看2408 南亞科也是一樣
僅限位置區哪邊
所以這個時候僅限位置區
這個很關鍵的這一條線就出來了
平常不一定要看這些線
現在僅限位置區
怎麼畫你不懂你來找我
像這個385 386
這邊也不太能跌破
懂不懂 OK嗎
教太多不行我不能再教了
我要汙住嘴巴
因為很多會員今天是很興奮的真的很興奮的來 彪我自己怕什麼啦是不是好 我只有跟大家講花旗喊台積電三千八
那你這喊都有機會
我覺得你喊台積電五千
比你喊
就兩個都攢一倍
就現在台積電攢到五千
跟年發哥攢到一萬
我寧願壓把年台積電攢到五千
所以台積電攢到五千也很喊
台銀只要5000的話
多多少
反正基本上台灣股市
可能再多個4萬點吧
哇
不是不可能嗎
以後越漲越快喔
是
數字越滾越快喔
所以我覺得川普唯一做的是
川普 account
就是川普帳戶你知道嗎
就是我錢可以放
然後可以什麼0到18歲
小孩子存一些錢
18歲以後就有錢了
他投資股票
其實最重要是負利
你們不要覺得下跌
是讓你們獲勝的最主要原因
所以說除了下跌還有負利
妳聽懂嗎
懂
妳可能聽不太懂我
妳可能越來越懂
錢滾錢很快
我講個最簡單的
妳通常是10%
妳100萬18多少
10萬妳好覺得很厲害
不好意思
其他起跑點不一樣
人家100億的10%
10億啊
是不是
郭台銘今天要拿鼓勵100多億啦
是
這社會不公平
對 這社會就不公平
妳要先了解這社會不公平
所以你要趕快
不要說滾到100億
你先滾到1000萬
然後滾到1000萬
滾到1億
這時候錢滾錢就很快
錢滾錢就很快
記得
好不好
錢滾錢就很快
財富自由後
就可以做很多事情了
好不好
OK嗎
來
記憶體感覺都好危險
頸部
對 頸線
對不對
記憶體感覺最近有點危險
因為什麼
因為南韓不對
因為這種
南韓這種大利多
這種跌法不對吧
一樣啊
三星這邊跌的價格
也不能跌破
有沒有到
頸線的位置區有沒有到
這三星的走勢
看到這都是
問你們
海力士
還好
海力士不要六月的低點跌破
所以你看
他們都沒有跌破六月份的低點
是不是
可是韓國股市很多跌破六月的低點
代表什麼意思
他們的記憶體
不是真正領跌
韓國的中小股在破了
你聽得懂嗎
我們在演出
這是六月份
有沒有看到這六月
對
六月的低點這邊
它現在在哪邊
然後從這邊看就知道
這六月嘛 這六月 這邊寫六月
它離六月的低點是還有一段距離
是
沒錯吧
沒錯
還有一段距離嘛 好
這是韓國走勢順便跟你講
來 三星離六月的低點差不多
差不多 是不是
可是你看海力士沒有
那三星這個代表是
它除了三星也不是純的記憶體
你知道嗎
你聽懂嗎
懂
哇 它有奇怪的4奈米 正成
其他的家電都有
所以代表是
他們最弱的不是記憶體
他們其他有一些部門
或其他的中小型個股
跌得滿凶
這樣懂不懂意思
來來 懂得懂哦
不懂沒關係
因為沒那麼重要
跌到焦慮感
6500人觀看
我就說等下會更高
應該有機會到6500到7000中間
好不好
華慢電工不營收
記憶體像
你知道嗎
像記憶體的營收
都可以不用看
你們會被迷惑
被困擾
日本的迷惑是困擾是不是
的意思
我不確定我日文沒那麼好
被什麼困擾
回到我剛剛跟你講的
來2002年
2003年
航海王什麼意思
藏農從20塊漲到223吧
漲200多塊的時候
再從200多塊
跌到100多塊的過程中
營收一直創新高
所以以什麼
記憶體現在不能只看基本面
要搭配技術面
這我今天最聳動的一句話
最務實的一句話
所以為什麼還是很多人看我節目
20年的分析是30年股市
30年以上
所以你看哲哲幫好
不好意思
信手年來都在我的腦海裡面
隨便講我都知道故事
story在哪裡
所以你現在記得是
記起來比記上去
現在你不能看記憶體的營收
不準了
早就反應完了
好不好
那基田都是6萬點的
說事實
我說老實話
真的不行隨時我會走
藍雅科我會走掉
我是跟大家講
我講得很清楚
我對你很好
來
再看一下
長龍內線炒股被抓
與其說內線炒股
我覺得是剛好在那時間買
那時間不能買賣股票
不能買賣股票 好不好
他們很簡單 就是
我想說就是兄弟在
我們不要講人家家務事
兄弟在細強 就這樣子
就是在扯遠的 扯遠的
我不要講 不要講
因為對我的股票
我其實知道很多內幕
沒有意義
來跟大家講
來來 買的紅海
紅海要不要先走
紅海這樣跌這邊反正不用走
簽譜機密可以
老師 投資長可以幫忙分析嗎
當然不行
我的股票就講不完了
南電區賺有機會散場
你若迷奇妙看我節目買別的股票
不理你 你們渣男 好不好
跟著哲哲老師不怕斬跌
資源還可以加碼嗎
我想加碼中美金
好不好 我是跟你講
我想加碼5347世界先進
好不好
資源 它是3萬點的股票
2萬點的股票
可不代表它會漲到6萬點
可是你說這跌下去呢
也大可不必
這樣聽得懂嗎
好不好 我已經
我再講下去暗示很清楚了
好不好
這個我講得不錯吧
現在幾分了
12差不多了
對 三星財報
三星財報其實不錯
所以我為什麼說現在不要看EPS
來 看一下
來 你們看一下為什麼不要看EPS
看一下講
用一下好了
來
看這邊
來 我們看一下這個
我們看看三星
三星年增1810%沒錯
不是1811
年增有沒有看到
從4.7兆含元
3到89.4兆
扯不扯
真的很誇張
是不是
好
可是市場居然
居然說為什麼間諜
因為市場平均84兆85兆
那89是不是很好
是不是
是啊
89嘛
很多人最愛嘛
8加9
扯遠的啦
開玩笑
沒有人身攻擊
除非你承認你是8加9
所以沒有人生攻擊
沒錯吧
好扯遠了啦
89扯遠了
89兆韓元
因為沒有達高標90兆到100兆
哪有這回事啦
你懂嗎
所以為了跌而跌啦
所以往好處想是
哎呀 可能像之前揮答啦
沒有達到超高標就跌那種委屈
可是揮答也是
這樣來過兩三次又怎麼樣
揮答現在也是要死不活啊
與其說要死不活
就是說他也高膽不墜
但也沒有上去了
你聽懂嗎
懂嗎
懂
所以現在不要只看基本面了
要看什麼基本面
除非它是跟你講說
哇 營收大幅衰退
那死定了
可是好的營收不一定要看
因為反應不了
這件事
2022年 2023年
航運股從200
從20元轉到200元
再從200元跌到
跌到100元以下的時候
那時候營收一直創新高
月跌營收創新高
所以現在記憶體
記得不要只看基本面
基本面的比重要降低
技術面的比重要提高
就是這個答案
相信我 你少讀十年股票的書
我對你們很好
基本面的比重要降低
技術面要提高
你看我平常很少講技術面
這時候要講技術面
藉由這句話 好不好
藉由這句話 可是
希望讓大家學到很多東西
好不好
我跟你講 有些東西
比如說 有些東西我是從大部分來講
比如CPU 我說有點是炒作
草作還是有人開靠草作也賺錢
我只是因為我的人粉數太多了
我就選一些的
就像我粉絲人多
我國劇有賺到錢
賺100%
然後賺100%左右
年發科賺個100多%
我就走了
走也是賺很多對不對
對
魚頭魚尾給人家賺
我們就當了股市渣男
股市渣男就好
一般渣男不要擔
採取人家最精華
最成長期那一段就好
然後就丟了
丟了說人家謝謝你
謝謝馮高承接
是很好 好不好
你看說維新是能跌多少
它也沒漲多少是能跌多少
一樣啊 技嘉也是一樣
能跌多少
它也沒漲多少能跌多少
所以一堆股票其實很抗跌
為什麼現在跌很
為什麼國際跌停板
就是因為它漲很多啊
是不是 3037 星星
還破底呢
是不是
這跟大家講
要準備破底
所以不論對我錯
我一切一切預告在前面
你去想想看
你要整個分析
想清楚了 想明白
哲哲你講很針對
哲哲我也好緊張喔
你不要緊張
為什麼你說不要緊張
來看一下
今天直播人數大概6500
剛才最高應該快7000嘛
應該6700差不多吧
差不多6700人
所以全台灣唯一100萬訂閱者的分析師
唯一一位喔
100萬
你不找我找誰
好不好
我們今天直播人數這麼多人
那我最後有告訴你
我說你趕快來參加行列
因為其實還是很多人
前撲後繼的進來
你看這件最新的新聞
什麼
保護 解約 解賬股市
保費進流出
一年來手建
我早就跟你講
我說傻了才放那麼多錢在保險
適當了就好了
傻了才把錢放在銀行定存
那些銀行家還不是拿去買美債
還不是拿去買台灣物股市
買VOO 買QQQ
不然呢
光看賺的利差
他們可以賺幾百億幾千億
你們真傻
那你把那些錢
不如這時候
該把錢投入股市
甚至加入行列
这是我认为
对某些人来讲是最佳的利益
最佳节
所以认同我讲的每一句话
现在有没有优惠
股市在给你优惠
最近好像收狗
台北市的收狗在打折
然后好像
因为有些贵姐贵哥会找我
好像最近好像新冠山又卡厉害
这些优惠顶多5%
不是一堆股票给你折扣10% 20%
打8%你不要
所以歡迎來電俏行
080668085
或加入我們那裡視訊我
不論對我有錯
走著一切一切的預告前面
去想想看人家的展示
想清楚了也歡迎怎麼樣
趕快來電報名
加入我們行列
我預祝各位能夠賺大錢
台灣多頭走勢依然不變
如果拉回
那是老天爺送給你禮物
拜拜
所推介分析之个别有价证券
无不当之财务利益关系
本节目资料仅供参考
投资人应独立判断
审慎评估并自负投资风险
谢谢大家